hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
we're I'm going be talking about how to
read the orderflow you know what do all
these numbers mean okay and this is a
orderflow footprint chart right and it
shows you the quantity traded on the bid
and the quantity traded on the offer at
price now this differs um from a dome
right if most people um automatically
assume that a dome is order flow because
it's the flow of orders going in and
some times trading or not trading being
pulled out of the market but let me ask
you this what do you think is more
important as a Trader to see people's
actual commitment to the market via
trades that they've done or you know the
orders that they're putting in away from
the market okay for me I believe that
the volume that actually trades is the
most important it's the most recent
information of what is taking place in
the market all right so before I jump in
if you enjoy learning from my videos
don't forget to subscribe and click the
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new uploads and if you find today's
video helpful hit that like button for
me and leave a comment sharing your
biggest takeaway all right I love
hearing your feedback so let's go ahead
and get started with today's topic all
right so you know how to read the order
flow for trading okay so if you're
looking at a dome right you know there's
prices on the bid there's prices on the
offer all right and if you're looking at
a footprint chart you know that there's
um actual trades taking place or
sometimes there's no trades taking place
at Price you know sometimes price can
skip uh sorry trading can Skip One price
level if the Market's moving pretty fast
okay so I'm going slide this Dome off my
chart here because really what I'm
focusing on when I'm reading the order
flow is the volume that was traded on
the bid versus the volume traded on the
offer right let me put the Dome back in
right markets trade in a two-way auction
there's a bid and there's an offer
and you need to take it a step further
right because understanding order flow
right the two-way auction is yes you
have a bid yes you have an offer okay
but for a trade to take place someone
needs to be aggressive someone needs to
cross that bid offer line so for example
going talk about gold today so you can
see here it's uh two uh sorry 20 29.6
offered at 20 29.8 last trade was 202
9.7 you have people that are bidding 9.6
people that are offering it at 9.8 for a
trade to take place someone on the bid
side has to go in and lift the offer or
someone on the offer side has to go down
and hit the bid now people that are
working offers these are called passive
Traders or sorry passive sellers people
that are working bids are passive buyers
okay so you have aggressive Traders and
you have passive Traders passive Traders
are the ones that are waiting for the
market to come to them right aggressive
Traders are the traders that want to get
into the position or out of the position
right now they are being aggressive
again remember markets won't move unless
there's aggressive trading someone
either lifting the offer or hitting the
bid so what do you how do you use that
information okay because when you look
at again when you're looking at a dome
you're seeing the passive offers the
passive sellers up here they're on the
offer and you see the passive buyers
down here whereas if you're looking at
the footprint you could actually see how
much traded at Price okay so for
example right here on this red Candle on
the edge I can see when the market was
20 29.6 at 20
29.7 16 traded on the bid at 9.6 18
traded on the offer at 9.7 in the this
bar okay these this is a one minute
chart and then it's from there right
it's from this information that I could
have what's called Delta Now Delta is
the difference between the aggressive
buyers and the aggressive sellers in a
bar so if a bar has positive Delta you
can see this bar has got two then it's
telling me that there was just two more
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in this bar but again who are the
aggressive Traders trading against
they're trading against the passive
Traders right aggressive buyers buy from
passive sellers aggressive sellers sell
the passive buyers again go back to your
Dome these are all passive sellers an
aggressive buyer would buy the
29.9 the 30.0 30. ons that's how the
market will move higher when the offers
get cleared out right aggressive buyers
are coming in and lift in this offer
then they lift the next next offer and
the next offer and the next offer
aggressive sellers move a market down
because there's passive buyers there's
biders in the market they're going to
sell you know the the 29.8 29.7 the 29.6
that's how a market moves down when the
aggressive sellers clear out the passive
buyers okay so now that you understand
that there's a difference between the
type of trading there's aggressive
trading and there's passive
trading when people are entering orders
into the market right away from the
market you know passive sellers or
passive buyers passive sellers right if
the market is trading 29.9 you know they
want to sell it up here at
30.7 what did why are they selling
generally they have
Supply they want to get rid of okay and
what causes a market to go down is not
just aggressive selling but strong
offers
that soak up all that aggressive buying
okay and again let me just show you what
I want to talk about here today um gold
okay so gold today you know we hit our
high early around 720 and then we sold
off made new lows at
33.6 right here all the way down to
25.4 okay now if you're looking at you
know a bar chart yeah you see lot of red
bars but if you're looking at a
footprint chart there's very strong
information that this Market can go
lower in the order flow okay so let's
take a look at
it um let's go back here to when we made
our
high 720 right yeah so here at 720 we
made a high right we got negative Delta
minus 49 right because we we had a high
selling came in aggressive selling came
in we've got 49 more
sellers aggressive sellers than
aggressive buyers that's what the Delta
is telling me okay see it's- 49 as the
market is going up right what is
happening the aggressive buyers are
present that's why you see positive
Delta 37 48 36 55 89 55 this is the
Delta down here at the
bottom you know a couple of red bars
here with negative Delta - 28 -
10 then 63 140 27 going into the new
highs and as you hit that new highs
aggressive selling came in now I'm not
saying this Market sold off because you
hit a high and you got aggressive
selling okay but once you're hit that
high aggressive sellers are coming into
the market right remember
price is essentially an advertising
mechanism right price gets to a certain
level Traders are going to look you know
do I want to be a buyer do I want to be
a seller right Traders are deciding they
want to be a seller Market sells off a
little bit starts to Rally back up sells
off some more into the new lows
so let's just pause for a
second if you have aggressive
buying moving the market higher
generally what do you expect to see you
expect to see positive Delta right
because the aggressive buying is
overwhelming the aggressive selling
that's what's causing the POS the Delta
to be
positive right if the Delta was negative
generally it's going to tell you that
there was more aggressive selling and
the market is trending down right or
starting to move down that's why you see
red bars have negative Delta right here
here
here and green bars have positive Delta
right just common sense generally right
but you know markets don't always
exhibit common sense and from the order
flow right there was a period this
morning before you know we were already
starting to sell off but before we broke
down into these new lows down here there
was a period here let me just uh draw a
box around it here where's my uh it's
control F12 rectangle um just going to
draw it from basically here down into
these lows here okay um let me just
change this uh opacity here I just
really just want the uh box I'll just
change this to uh
transparent okay so you see this box
area here
Market is going down right you got red
candles that's what you expect to see
okay but what's unique about this move
lower is you got positive
Delta right 22 22 5 24 9 86 76 then You'
break down you know almost another 10
bucks here from this level from these
new lows you know often times we make a
low we bounce up off of it right but
here this is that area right in here
right and then we broke down from um you
know 33 A2 all the way down into the
mid2 so about an $8 move um so why do
you have you know why is this Market
going
down with the Positive Delta right
shouldn't the market be going up with
basically overall positive Delta right
positive 76 positive 86 these are quite
strong that's why there this this blue
color you know this Delta is telling me
that the Delta is closing it's sort of
at its Max Delta its strongest positive
Delta reading yet the market is going
lower what the heck does that
mean well it means that Supply is coming
into the market that's absorbing
whatever aggressive buying is taking
place I mean look at this here let make
this bigger so you can see 176 on the
offer here right you had a strong seller
big passive seller that was there to
absorb whatever aggressive buying was
taking place
here okay because remember right markets
move up on aggressive buying and
generally right if Market is moving up
on aggressive buying it's going to take
out higher and higher
levels right price levels but if there's
a big seller in here that is basically
absorbing all that aggressive
buying eventually one or two things is
going one of two things is going to
happen that seller is going to run out
of bullets or the buyer's going to run
out of bullets right either the
aggressive sellers going to be like
that's it I can't sell anymore I've out
of inventory or the aggressive buyers
are going to be like they're out of
bullets right they can't buy anymore
they got no more buying power okay so
one thing is going to
give and
then once that gives well who wins in
this case the people that are working
the offers and you could just see it in
here right you see this bar 22 positive
Delta why it's because up here right
look at these volumes on the offer okay
now 11's not big but
1825 this bar it only trades 100
contracts this is a a one minute gold
chart but you can see how the volume on
the offer side is much stronger than the
volume on the bid side so there was
strong aggressive buying don't get me
wrong 25 181 but that is being absorbed
by the passive
sellers okay so these aggressive
buyers you know they're sort of running
out of money to buy more then the market
drops just naturally once you remove
that buying pressure okay it goes
sideways a little bit similar thing look
at the volumes 22 18 now here you got 10
18 17 but it's just slightly stronger
here the 22 and the
18 okay then this one again negative
Delta minus 17 but still you're seeing
some decent volumes on the offer side 29
34 and positive Delta here 24 so you got
a 37 you got 28 right two of your
heaviest volumes are on the offer side
just like this bar okay then the similar
thing coming in this red candle 18 14
here your heaviest volume is
14 okay this bar is kind of mixed then
you see you know the big seller is
finally showing his hand here
176 so this Market is moving down okay
so think about it for a second okay and
it's hard to see on a dome because what
is going on is the market is moving down
and the offers there's a strong passive
offers that are also coming down lower
so what do you have you have a
combination of people hitting the bids
clearing those out but you also you also
have strong offers coming in helping to
push the market down that anytime there
is aggressive buying taking place it's
being absorbed by the offers okay and
honestly a lot of times you don't see it
because people use icebergs in the
market but on a footprint chart it's
very clear and if you know that we're
coming into the low and you got very
strong um Supply in the market how do I
know it's Supply become as passive
sellers people that are there to absorb
whatever aggressive buying is taking
place you know they don't need to and
again if you have Supply and you're a
seller a big seller institutional
Trader you don't need to come in and
clear out all the bids let the retail do
that you're there to absorb whatever
aggressive buying is taking place and
you just step it lower step it lower
step it lower right you can see down
here 189 even
okay and all that took
place right right in
here
basically
okay just this little area right in
here uh
transparent right preceding that big
move down now I'm not saying you know
you you cover it down here but you know
you're talking a move from you know 34
33 60 even after you break this low at
33 there's plenty of time to be getting
short here at around the 33 l level then
it quickly breaks down in you know into
you know the 28 is 28 to 29
area Okay so that's how you can use what
you're seeing on the footprint
chart right in
here put the pieces of the puzzle
together right all you got to be looking
is hey you know what we're going lower
on positive Delta right if we're going
if we're putting in posit positive Delta
and again it's not just that you got one
bar with positive Delta you're stringing
bars together this is 1 2 3 4 then
negative then positive then negative
then positive then positive positive
okay so you're really Str together you
know four in here well even ifcl this
five right in here although it's a green
bar but four plus one in here okay as
the market is moving down you that
should get your attention hey we're
going lower on positive Del maybe
there's some Supply creeping into this
Market that I could take advantage of
all right so that wraps up today's video
on you know how to use the volumes in
the orderflow especially the Delta so I
hope you found these tips helpful for
your understanding of orderflow and if
you enjoyed this video be sure to hit
the like button and subscribe to my
channel so you don't miss any upcoming
uh videos thanks for watching being a
part of my community your support is
appreciated I'll see you guys on the
next video
bye-bye